this woman doesn't want to reveal her
real identity she wants to be known as
Lily she's had an abortion
a crime in Ireland that could get her 14
years in prison her doctor - even though
in her case the fetus was severely
impaired the decision to terminate the
pregnancy wasn't easy for Lily and her
husband there were two options available
to us that we could carry the baby to
term and the the baby would die after
delivery or we could travel out of the
jurisdiction and have a termination we
left the hospital and went for a long
walk and on the beach and quickly
decided that we didn't really have any
other option but to travel to the UK
Lily sought help at a clinic in
Liverpool sneaking across to England and
secrets even now she and her husband are
very careful about who they confide in
only a small number of our family know
about Australia to the UK other people
weren't just told we had a miscarriage
because that's was the more socially
acceptable you know it is it is
something that is against the law here
so there is that conflict but I had to
do what was right for me and for my
family so that was the most important
thing and it is hard not to be able to
talk about it openly and not to be able
to explain what really happened Amnesty
International says Irish women are being
forced to go abroad for abortions
Ireland has no jurisdiction over
abortions carried out elsewhere but
Irish society stigmatizes both women and
their doctors regardless of whether or
not there are prosecutions to
criminalize women and girls to
criminalize health professionals
when it comes to providing either
information our access to abortion is a
human rights violation it's contrary to
best practice and medical ethics etc as
well prenatal counseling centers are
especially hard-hit radical pro-life
activists have been known to report
anyone involved in aiding the abortion
process sometimes resorting to extreme
methods such as secretly videotaping
counselors clients came in to various
clinics pretending to be a client who
had an online pregnancy and their
intention was that we would be seen to
be breaking the law by making phone
calls or providing money or referring I
was taped we were all investigators it
went to the DPP which would be Ireland's
source before it goes to court and it
wasn't brought to course there was no
case proven nevertheless supporters of
legalized abortions are often socially
ostracized as potential murderers I
think even if the kid is sick even if
there the debt the doctors say they're
gonna die hours after they're born
that's still their life I think even a
short life or a sick life is life a
majority of members of parliament agree
with this view so in a nation where some
80% of the population are Catholics no
liberalisation of the abortion laws is
in sight
even if polls show a large majority of
Irish citizens would favor it
I think abortion should be legalized yes
why because I think it's a woman's body
and she should have the right to choose
there's a lot of people who are still
quite old-fashioned and it's the
old-fashioned voters that always show up
for the referendums but that's what's
really started to for now seeing
significant very significant levels of
public support and increasingly we're
seeing political support but weaver with
a long way to go politics is and
government and political leaders are
very very far behind public opinion on
this issue around 4,000 Irish women are
known to travel abroad for an abortion
every year the true figure may be much
higher
most Western countries describe their
own more liberal abortion laws as an
expression of a woman's right to decide
over her own body but Lily and her
husband felt they had little choice when
they had the birth induced prematurely
in Liverpool
they knew the baby had virtually no
chance of survival
and the following afternoon our little
boy was born he was dead and sort of
late that night by the time I was
returned to my room and my husband was
there and then they brought the baby in
and his cold cos so we spent the night
in the room with the baby the Catholic
Church's stance on abortion effectively
blocked the liberalization of the
abortion laws lily is Catholic but she
feels the church has failed her if we'd
been able to have the termination here
we could have brought him home and had a
wake for him or you know had a proper
ceremony but he arrived home by courier
and a dusty old envelope it's not a very
it's just a very undignified way to come
home Ireland's ban on abortions force
Lily to turn to a clinic abroad but she
hopes she can bury her child in Irish
soil